i wouldn't leave my room when i started
getting really really
really dark and i'm
yelling on the phone and like the
barrels in my mouth megan's like dead
silent machine gun kelly opens up about
a suicide attempt which led the singer
to making some big changes in his
personal life i've never seen anyone be
able to self-sabotage more than me
i'm like
the best self-sabotager i've ever
witnessed the revelation is part of
mgk's hulu documentary life in pink
which is streaming now in it he shares
intimate details from behind the curtain
i told the hospital i said if if it
looks bad like he'd call me
and they called me
they put the phone up to his ear and he
took his last breath that was the last
time i
heard from my father as mgk explains the
death of his father in 2020 sent him
into a downward spiral he also reveals
he was battling depression and substance
abuse at the time when his
then-girlfriend now fiance megan fox
headed off to film a movie things took a
turn for the worse
i wouldn't leave my room when i started
getting really really
really dark like
megan went to bulgaria to shoot a movie
i started getting this really wild
paranoia like i kept getting paranoid
that someone was gonna come and kill me
and there was this i would always sleep
with this shotgun next to my bed
and like
one of the days i just
[ __ ]
snapped
this culminated in a particularly
frightening moment while he was on the
phone with megan
called megan did i put the shotgun in my
mouth
and i'm
yelling on the phone and like the
barrels in my mouth
and i go to [ __ ] the shotgun and the
bullet as it comes back up the shell
just gets jammed
megan's like dead silent
that was kind of where
i started realizing like
something's not
right mgk doesn't specifically name what
substances he was using at the time but
he says megan and his now 12 year old
daughter casey forced him to make a big
change they simultaneously kind of
came at me
with this like
i want to like be able to see in your
eyes
i don't want i don't want to like
be talking to you through a veil anymore
i want to like
see you as my father and i want to see
you as my
um
you know husband to be casey also
appears in the documentary as she tells
it her dad found healthier ways to cope
i also like once he stopped doing drugs
so now he gets like addicted to other
things to like supply
that feeling he's always working so it's
like when i'm around now it's like work
work work work work yeah he keeps plenty
busy in the studio and on the big screen
mgk recently made his directorial debut
with good morning a film he also wrote
and starred in you're an idiot i hope
you find your girlfriend yeah megan's in
it too but their most important gig to
date their upcoming wedding how is the
wedding planning going i know obviously
you've been looking for the right
location for the right gothic vibe how's
it going i'm going to leave that kind of
like a a present for the world to unwrap
when it happened
[Music]